so you you mentioned that there are
these think tanks with rosters or Maga
types uh ready to head into government
and take office
um so let's look at the Republican field
for a minute you have Trump who probably
would take advantage of these lists so
one of the things
um that I'd be concerned about is that
essentially whoever even is able to
Elbow Trump aside might think okay the
way I won is by being trumpy so I'm
going to hire the the Trump type crew uh
I don't I don't suppose you have any
sense as to who else is thinking in the
same way well I I think it's highly
likely in fact you know one of the
comments that someone gave me in the
book was that it would be a nightmare
slate of political appointees regardless
of its uh of whether it's the next Trump
because the people that are being lined
up for these top jobs have to survive a
purity test and that purity test is did
they stand with the Republican Party
When Donald Trump was at the head of it
so certainly don't expect to see any
never Trump Republicans in the next
Republican Administration but I'd be
hard-pressed uh to to you know predict
that we would see any former Bush
Republicans or moderates uh go in
because a lot of those people don't pass
that purity test that these think tanks
which will staff the next Administration
want them to staff
um and you know what worries me about
this Andrew in particular is because
folks would be coming into these
departments and agencies carrying
forward again some of these thwarted
policies from Trump's first term I mean
one of the ones that caught me really
off guard while I was writing this book
had to do with veterans and I wanted to
make sure that I talked to senior
officials who had run agencies almost
every agency in the Trump Administration
and when I went and talked to people at
the Department of Veterans Affairs I
actually didn't expect to hear a whole
lot I I hadn't interacted with the VA
very much but I wanted to check the box
and some of these people are on the
record in my book Trump's hand-picked
appointees that were writing uh running
the Department of Veterans Affairs under
him and one of the things that I didn't
know about that they wanted to do in the
first term was in their words destroy
the Department of Veterans Affairs and
you might ask why why would Trump want
to destroy the agency that exams to
serve veterans yeah he found out that it
had the second biggest budget in the
federal government the VA is a 250
billion dollar a year organization Trump
wanted to take a wrecking ball to the
organization to move that money to other
political priorities again you may say
that can't possibly true be true why
would Trump want to do that well we know
from quotes from Trump's former Chief of
Staff John Kelly and others that he has
a very negative view towards veterans
because he himself tried to Dodge
service in the military during the
Vietnam war he called Veterans that died
on the battlefield during World War II
and the Normandy invasion quote suckers
and losers for not surviving those
attacks and now we see it manifested in
his plans for the Department of Veterans
Affairs which he wanted to yank out that
social safety net from under veterans
his former deputy secretary again
Trump's own former deputy secretary of
the department said thousands if not
millions of veterans would be thrown out
on the streets if they had carried out
his plans to destroy the VA the only
reason Trump was talked out of this was
not because the officials told him
veterans would die if he did this and
they did There's documentation that
officials at the VA told the White House
veterans will die by the thousands if
you move forward with these plans the
only reason he was talked out of it was
because they said you might lose
re-electin because you'll lose the
veterans community if you do this in a
first term and so Trump said okay and
they put pause on these plans plans that
will be implemented by the way if he
wins a second term they want to rip the
VA to shreds to use that money elsewhere
now make no mistake the Department of
Veterans Affairs desperately needs
reform okay veterans Health Care has
been an issue for a long time but taking
a wrecking ball to it and getting rid of
it overnight
would hurt millions of people who've
served our country in uniform that was
one of the things I was told while
writing this book that really disgusted
me I mean absolutely stunning uh and I
put it in the book and again these Trump
appointees who were on the receiving end
of these orders are quoted by name yeah
that is disgusting I mean uh no we we
owe veterans uh a lot uh and certainly
uh need to deliver on our promises as
opposed to trying to take a wrecking
ball to the VA it's terrible
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you